so when I started they show the whole
the whole point is that I wanted to sort
of take current events and for people
that don't care about it that much that
you could get some information so I'm
gonna give you kindergarten 101 Ukraine
I'm catching up on it all myself at the
moment so basically we know we had the
riots and protests in the Ukraine about
two weeks ago the president of the
Ukraine wanted to align more with Russia
for economic reasons it seems the people
wanted to go more towards the EU then
Russia invaded although we didn't call
it invasion for a few days they've now
taken control of the Crimean Peninsula
Putin saying that we're not or Putin or
Putin I guess that's like the the Bronx
thing saying that you know we're not
really invading so there's there's a lot
of questions here I know it's a big
thing so I want to give sort of a
general overview of the whole thing but
let's start this is President Obama
speaking about Ukraine yesterday I think
that we've all seen that from the
perspective of the European Union the
United States allies like Canada and
Japan and allies and friends and
partners around the world there is a
strong belief that Russia's action is
violating international law I know
President Putin seems to have a
different set of lawyers making a
different set of interpretations but I
don't think that's fooling anybody I
think everybody recognizes that although
Russia has legitimate interests in what
happens in a neighboring state that does
not give it the right to use force as a
means of exerting influence inside of
that state okay so I think that's an
interesting place to start because Obama
is talking about Putin's lawyers as if
Putin was sitting around with a bunch of
guys going guys you know Kranepool and
Schmidt what are we doing here can we do
this is this legal so I want to start
with that element of it I feel like
we're on two different planets right
here like Putin's going I'm invading I
have guys that maybe you're dressed like
Russian soldiers maybe not but I'm gonna
do this thing and we're debating as if
this is something that's going on in a
in a court room with lawyers is that is
that the fundamental problem that we're
not even on the same
playing field here well I mean I think
that I mean war is such an emotional I
mean I think personally that it's such
an emotional kind of move and you look
at the wars through history and they're
you know they're not there's no rules
fair in love and war you know but what I
read this morning was that Merkel
basically said that Putin is like out of
his mind he's crazy he's crazy and when
you have somebody like that I mean like
what are you gonna do I mean like Hitler
I mean like what are you gonna do yeah
you know I it's one of the things that's
come up is that when we would go to the
UN looking for you know to go to Syria
or go to you know for intervention or
for whatever that Russia would love to
use it always would use its veto power
to say like nope we're not going to do
like nope and so the question is like
why aren't they going to the UN and if
this is just an intervention so you're
saying they're not standing up to their
ideas they would hold us do I can't
believe it but they would old us - I
mean like we've given the best example
and you want to invade a country you go
and you lie to the UN and tell them that
there are weapons that you tell them but
now it's it's an like an invasion by any
other name would it be as a whole like
yeah it's anything can be rationalized
if you want if you want to go in right
yeah but then isn't that the fundamental
problem if we have potentially this
crazy guy that's actually using military
force is part of this that everyone we
just know that Obama is not into the
military and I'm not saying that that's
bad I don't want to be all everyplace
it's good that we're pulling back from
from parts of the world but that Putin
can do whatever he was because he knows
Obama is not gonna be like you know
we've already had the red line thing
once we're serious so he can pretty much
do whatever he wants right yeah you know
all I can say is I hope not I hope not
because I mean you look at these crazies
all over you go get that you know the
Korea and and and they're all over the
place and they have to be they have to
be stopped I mean once they're
completely irrational
don't you think they feel like they can
do whatever they want for right or wrong
whether
they should do whatever they want to how
much influence the United States is a
separate issue but don't they feel like
they can Putin's man that that hunts
Tigers and flies with birds he clearly
thinks he can do whatever he want he
he's been under immense pressure for the
past what seven months about the LGBT
laws in his country as he was on the
world stage for the Olympics and they
didn't so much as blink like there's no
you know there is II didn't say anything
didn't even like repudiate it really
like there was no yeah there was no real
pushback on that issue and that really
is an issue that would have been very
easy for everybody to come out and be
like no we don't want to go to the
Olympics then oh no we don't want to you
know in this case like this is actually
like war this is a I don't think that we
have the stomach for it right now yeah I
think we're gonna hope that it doesn't
come to us going there yeah we're gonna
talk about some of the LGBT stuff later
but doesn't it now in retrospect with
the Olympics only being two or three
weeks over doesn't it actually seem nuts
that the Olympics were there especially
if you listen to all the commentators
they're like oh we knew this was
happening I actually didn't watch it and
notice you didn't miss much except but
you know what I just because it is what
his eyes that's oh that's what I've
heard about it but I have to all have to
look that up but the thing is that and I
know I wasn't making a difference
I mean by not watching but I couldn't do
it I mean it was so I was so social were
actually like having a form of protest
yeah I was just like sickened by it and
I loved the events I mean I really have
always enjoyed watching it but the whole
elements of it I mean I just loved
watching you know buddy Cole on you know
Steven go I mean Scott tops and I mean
that was that was wonderful and I
thought that was great that they did
that but it was horrible it was more
than I had and I was so disappointed in
our country yeah pretty much
in retrospect should we not have even
gone I guess it's easy to say now I I
mean I personally had an issue with us
going before like it's hard because the
Olympians obviously work their whole
lives and they want you know but at the
same time sometimes it's worth taking a
stand and yes coca-cola will be upset
because they're sponsoring the event and
NBC will be upset because they paid so
much money to
broadcast it and so of course there was
no chance we were going to not go but I
think we should have yes I mean does
anybody know I and I can understand that
people who have been athletes and
working towards this really wouldn't
want to forgo it but I have there been
any athletes who said that they didn't
want to go who were you know about to go
and I mean did anybody might have been
one from I guess it Trump one Trump's
the other pretty quickly and that's kind
of sad that's a final thought on Ukraine
since we're probably gonna be talking
about this for months if not years what
should the United States role in the
world be can I end with a bigger
question than that I mean really should
do we have any right we go into
countries when we want to we've still
got drones going in Pakistan and
Afghanistan right now and and many other
places what right do we have do we have
a right anymore to tell anyone what to
do it's such a it's such a huge question
and it really goes back so many so many
so many steps because everything starts
with education everything starts with
education and education is a very
long-term goal and if people aren't
educated they act like have visceral
responses to everything in there idiots
exactly so if you don't start with that
and you don't be a you can't communicate
with people then you're going to have
knee-jerk reactions there's gonna be
violence
so I mean ideally what would be good is
a dialogue an international dialogue so
that people can discuss this and act
like adults but they don't act like
adults and we may have one guy that
we've all said might be crazy which we
have a little bit of his trouble time
talking also I think we're kind of
seeing the ill effects of what happens
when you go to wars that are unpopular
worldwide and are seen as aggressive and
you see you lose that moral standing and
that were high ground where you know if
we had never done that you know
hindsight being 20/20 but if we had
never done that we have a little bit
more moral authority to be like no this
is where we go in and maybe this is the
one we choose to go to as opposed to but
I feel like Iraq and Afghanistan have
made us so gun-shy because we
it's like well do we just want to do
this every time you know and it makes it
hard leadership for sure but it's it
hard to pick what's the right one when
we've we have bad history of the wrong
ones recently so there you go so yes
sometimes got by going to the wrong war
you actually enable yourself to go to
possibly what could be the right one not
that I'm saying we should be going to
war but it does limit your chance it's
been a final [ __ ] okay but like looking
strolling Hayden's
character and dr. Strangelove I mean he
was he was kind of like your Putin in
this example he's nuts
he's absolutely nuts and he needs to be
taken out yeah I mean if you're nuts
you need to be eliminated not the
country the person targeted
assassinations by taki live men ladies
and gentlemen